if you laid all the rails end to end and
it's probably for high or three high she
laid them all end to end you'd have
eight and a half miles of costume and
we've got just over a million pieces so
it's quite a lot of costume
we go from the 20s to the 30s and this
is ladies night wear evening dresses and
on the left hand side we now go to 1940s
again all original these are all
production rails we're now hitting 1810
we call it Georgian we're walking down
this run and if you bear in mind that
there's probably 12 other runs as long
as this running parallel with this and
then crisscrossing it there's further
costumes one of my favorite rooms is now
coming up on our right hand side which
is our armory when we started doing Game
of Thrones this particular black outfit
over here we did all the costumes for
the wall that as the series progressed
they made all their own outfits but this
was one of the original night's night's
watch I think the interesting story is
that when we make clothes we're making
them exactly the same way that we'd have
made them in 1840 I'm of course now
there's electricity and there's electric
machines but we're making them exactly
the same kate's launcher actually said
that when she puts on a costume from
here it actually helps her in her
performance
we did have an auction a few years ago
we did have obi-wan Alec Guinness is
obi-wan Kenobi robe we did auction it
and it went for a lot of money if we've
got original iconic looks like that will
keep them somewhere all will auction
them because we're not a museum you know
this this doesn't exist anywhere in the
world when we started doing movies back
in 1913 so we're older than the movie
industry itself you know because we were
going from 1840 so it is a great
resource we have to protect that
resource because this is rather like a
huge food court two moths you know I
mean you've got one section that could
be McDonald's another Kentucky Fried
Chicken or up-market restaurants you
know apart from moths I think how our
worst fear is computer generation
because in the old days back in the day
you'd supply 2,000 uniforms now you
probably supply 200 and they can make
them look like 2,000 and so and I mean
they can even take dead actors now and
finish a movie if someone dies in the
middle of a movie so I don't know where
it goes but I think there will always be
a need for clothes I hope